all you guys out there know what I'm
talking about birthday sex y'all know
what I'm talking about right hey
everybody I'm Terry Crews and I am
headed to the GQ Men of the Year party
let's go
let's see what it is say hi cherry along
the way to the men of the Year party you
will have the complete GQ experience
enjoy your time on route I like this I
like this even the card smell good this
is kind of nice
I'm feeling the vibe look at us we're
actually moving in LA it's question time
what does man of today mean to you the
man of the day is a man who's willing to
admit his faults but he's also willing
to correct each and every one of them
who is the best-dressed man coach every
crew I gotta go with Terry Crews if you
don't believe in yourself who are you
gonna believe in what am I most proud of
you know hey I am proud of my family
anybody who knows me knows that I put my
family first
the last president I received birthdays
Christmas Arbor Day
I get sex my wife she knows what the
dude I don't want anything that she
knows what to give you knows how to make
brother a happy man okay birthday sex is
best I'm going on to the next question
what would you want your biopic to be
titled and who would play you well check
it out my biopic will be called manhood
just like my book and you know what I
would probably have it just overplayed
me I make him play with a British accent
where I my name is Terry Crews I'm
growing up I came up to Michigan
all right look at this car it says let's
get personal I'm gonna be quick with
this what is my favorite emoji the smile
what is the last text message you sent
it was hey I'm heading to the GQ minute
a year party y'all
ha ha ha lol I think I have one of those
emojis on it to go to karaoke song
making my way downtown walking fast
faces pass and I'm home bound favorite
item of clothing shoes are the basis of
a whole ensemble your shoes suck your
whole outfit you got the best suit in
the world with bad shoes and it's around
I hate it when people say at the end of
the day when you hear someone say at the
end of the day they don't know what
they're talking about
I love it when you see a group of people
women men all races colors Creed's
everybody getting together and
respecting each other equally it's the
best thing in the world man what is the
worst thing a man in the year can do at
this party because it's kind of like
that Christmas party thing where I had a
little too much drink and people get a
little too honest and they go you know
I've always liked black people please
don't drink too much what I am looking
forward to tonight is just meeting some
of my heroes meeting some of the people
that I've looked up to for years I'm
prepared to be inspired tonight
hey I'm Terry Crews thank you for
watching this video please subscribe to
the GQ channel for more videos just like
this one
you